Miriam why do we need events like this
still in 2014 does it surprise you that
so many girls think career options are
closed off to them no it doesn't
surprise me I think that you know we
have made a lot of progress but there is
a still a little bit more progress to to
make and I think that it is good for the
girls to see as many options as are
available for them there I think that
this events are very little effort
really all that we are asking for is one
hour of time per woman per year
everybody can do it
so it's a fantastic occasion and I feel
it is also important to realize that
Thetis it is for the girls is is very
good for the women who participate as
well and energy and that question in
lots of things about your own life with
the same thing now you've got three boys
so they is the advice you give to the
girls hair any different than you would
give to your own boys none necessarily I
you know I go on with my boys also about
how do you have to make an effort and
how everything really depends on you and
if you really want to summarize what I
hope that at the end of the whole
litigation process they would remember I
much hope it is that I do think they
know that I have done a lot of talking
to girls we have been all around the
country we have been in Manchester and
Liverpool and Birmingham and Essex and
they're here in Glasgow in London you
know lots of different combinations but
something I have really noticed that I
do not see so much with boys is that we
get lots of questions about
self-confidence say I wonder whether
there is there is something a little bit
specific to girls there and in
particularly in relation to certain
subjects and science subjects but it
catches my attention that I get a lot of
questions about where did you get your
self-confidence which I find very
surprising because in the film that they
think that that we the women have
self-confidence and interestingly a lot
of people say in their careers that
sometimes women do lack that
self-confidence maybe to push for
promotions
push for more money is that something
that you think women perhaps need to
address why I don't know whether that is
specific to women but insofar as it may
affect women yes I do think that it is
important to celebrate female
achievement and that you know aiming
high and that is part of the message
that we want to give to the girls that
aiming high is guilt it's as good for
girls as it is for boys so you've done
very well you've got a really successful
we have we feel so successful underway
today identity well to us and you as I
understand
child care is very very expensive tell
me do you think you need to be wealthy
to have it all as a working mother I
think that would what I would take issue
with in your question is they have it
all I never understand what people mean
when they say have it all I I personally
have never wanted to have it all like a
general aim I just want to have what men
have you know a lots of men have a
successful professional life or what
looks like success to them and they have
put that together with a family so that
is what I want to have there would be
other women who don't want to deserve
that and I think it's also important to
realize that they all is quite different
to lots of different women and indict a
lot of different men but Iker is is an
issue obviously and I think that as I
think that it was Sheryl Sandberg said
the most important decision in your life
is who you decide to have children with
that was the most important decision in
your life so my question on that really
is we were reading recently about a
power couple where they said they'd
written down the tests that you do in
the home 40 odd tasks and the man
realized he only fulfilled five of them
it did look like they had a very
balanced life do you think that is the
case for women that they still tend to
take on the burden at home as well I
think I did this changing a lot and
there are lots of couples who share more
and more I think that there are lots of
men know that are fully involved with
racing the the children I think that
probably if you look at cross
xiety and probably across different
country certainly in what's called the
western world women still gets a very
big proportion of the chores at home and
i certainly do know a lot of women that
before they leave the door to go to work
they have done kind of half a day at
home and then when they come back from
their daily jobs they have the other
half
waiting there but I think that it is
changing a lot tonight is not for me and
I it's not an issue for women like you
or I but we can get help it is for the
people who cannot get help you don't
have the money to get help perhaps who
don't have their money or the
circumstances to get help on that point
that you said you talked about how you
just want women to be able to be like
men a lot of these girls who you've met
today not yet but one day they will be
in relationships with men who might have
their own ambitions and that can
sometimes be difficult I mean how do you
compromise that do you ever feel that
you've had to put your own life on pause
to support who's a very obviously
successful husband not on pause but I
think that you know having a family and
unlife indeed is all about compromises
say I never go around this taking notes
about you know the series days and next
series whatever and I think that indeed
most people don't but there is always a
certain equilibrium and you in my case
we found it naturally but I do
understand that there are people who
plan this is I'm just not very good with
them
yeah well they sometimes when the Prime
Minister's away your husband of course
has to run the country so presumably you
pick up the slack then we think the
cherried externally and we you know we
make the point of one of us being at
home most evenings and I think that on
the whole we manage but in different
families organize their lives very
differently and there is no you know
there is no given formula because it's
mercy there are different values and
different preferences to do everybody I
think that in a family
do you have a good feeling of when
things are working for the children and
certainly the children are with the
prayers introduced ask you here these
this inspiring women event and all of
them are about girls and state schools
do you feel that there's an additional
boost needed for children in state
schools to inspire them in this way is
it because they don't come across as
many role models or no but I do thin and
that I have learned a lot from sparing
the future we do which it was something
that I didn't know so Matt said at the
beginning I do think that there is an
issue of self confidence in some of
these schools i I have now traveled a
lot and done lots of these events I have
met fantastic girls truly fantastic that
you think you know you have a bright
future if you push it a tiny bit and and
in many cases I have got the message
from the teachers you know they don't
really feel confident enough about being
in this particular social environment or
about doing this and that as I wouldn't
be if we can help I couldn't be helped
it's not too much of an effort is it and
on that note I very much hope that
you're ready is there and that you got
your friends so yes no absolutely
absolutely very last very clear in the
future website yes thank you and in 2010
I loved the fact that you said you'd
help out in the election but not all the
time because you're a busy woman you're
a career woman and we know that Justine
and Samantha have also done inspiring
women which is a great thing just
blasting does it ever frustrate you when
parts of the media focus on you as the
wife of someone else
no if if that makes them like you come
into this event and if I can look back
in March next year and to say that we
have left here 15,000 volunteers with a
campaign that I can have a life on its
own
I actually welcome it